hold on you watch saki uh yeah and you
gave it a seven
sakisaki that's the one with the things
on his ear that's the yeah yeah
the the the one yeah that's the the body
pillow we have yeah yeah yeah yeah i
watched that
you've actually watched i didn't even
watch it i watched all of saki
and i i hope at the end i was like i'm
going to understand and at the end i was
like i don't understand
i'm like but there's golden wind and
[ __ ] going on and stuff like that
i don't know so okay again it just
doesn't seem like a show you would watch
i watched
all of persona 4 the animation i noticed
that i noticed that as well
you've never played persona 4 never
played persona why why would you do that
i didn't i i'll on i'll be 100 with you
at the time i legitimately didn't know
it's a game
that's like that's like that wait did
you watch danganronpa as well yeah yeah
he did he gave me
a play dunk give it a four i have played
danganronpa i thought the anime was
actually okay
that's fine that's fine um if for the
shows that i haven't rated you can ask
me and ask me what i'd give it okay what
would you give a no game no life
oh if i was four if i was 14 yeah i got
a hard 10. yeah
yeah yeah now like a seven honestly
seven okay
it's it's it's it's about that what
would you give excel
uh you know like uh like a four
what would you give another like a like
a one
all right another was [ __ ] well you
watched b got the hk as well
you know okay actually i i did i love
beagles yeah that is funny that's
actually like a [ __ ] gracious
i can tell you exactly why i watched
another as well uh because i was talking
to a girl at the time
and she was like of course my favorite
show is another
it's the best show and i was like all
right fine i'll watch this show because
i'm trying to like simp
i'm trying to send pierce so i'll try it
yeah another was kind of like the kind
of like the true crimes documentary the
anime community
yeah you know what i mean everyone knows
white girls love true crime
yeah and before they get into true crime
you know they're a little younger
they're like another
yes erased yes you know all these shows
that i love it's just like yes i too
like final destination and watching
trashy horror movies
i can do that all day long that's
literally what sydney gets me to do
whenever i
like okay i'll give you i'll give you
props though that you a
watched claymore and gave it a nine
honestly
i loved claymore playing was [ __ ]
awesome man i that is one of the
animes that got done most dirty yeah
yeah that's that's what i'm supposed to
give it a nine because claymore manga
manga nine or ten claymore manga
masterpiece
the anime made me like feel things that
i hadn't felt before man i was like
what is that like a level of
uncomfortableness that i haven't
experienced before yeah like i don't
know why there's something so unnerving
and uncomfortable about watching
claymore yeah
i i felt that when i watched berserk
yeah
it's like kind of [ __ ] it like [ __ ] you
up a little bit and yeah i can tell like
i honestly i wish i i'm i'm going to try
my best to try and read the manga but i
said i was going to read something
i recently rebought all the manga just
because i want to read it again because
what was the other [ __ ] show i said i
was going to read the manga earlier uh i
have no [ __ ]
no no you finished action 21 right yeah
yeah i did i wanted after that
well uh i i actually i downloaded uh
this first one was it no no no i
was gonna read that but i actually
downloaded the first 30 chapters of one
piece being like
oh he's getting old
but i haven't i haven't stopped i
haven't had the stomach market marketing
you count
va starts listen i'll tell you when i
start like
but i haven't marketing your calendars
and come back to us in 10 years time
we'll see where he is but honestly like
claymore
is a [ __ ] amazing manga one of the
best mangas out there
anime did it dirty is the is the manga
finished like totally
[Music]
yeah and it was complete [ __ ] from what
i remember yeah i remember having a good
time
i remember i watched the dub i remember
the voice acting was uh greg
as was like playing the whiny character
as he always does and i think he was a
little too windy
i mean that's just greg heiress
he's too [ __ ] good at his job no no
because like i remember that was like
i swear he was typecasting that rolf
like the longest [ __ ] because there
were so many of those characters and no
one else could do a voice like him
like sounding whiny yeah and so it's
always him doing the whiny character
i will say a wrecker seven seven out of
ten honestly
i went original one when i watched that
everyone was talking about the show
like jesus had came down himself and
brought a show yeah and i watched it and
i thought
honestly this is kind of [ __ ] like it's
it's good but like it's kind of [ __ ]
boring
like is that how you feel about it
obviously now i would give it a six is
that how you felt about ergo proxy as
well you gave that a seven as well
oh girl proxy i remember i was just like
what the [ __ ] is happening
again this doesn't seem like an anime
that you would watch no like the
ergo proxy is the last anime i would
think it was like watching
like you don't go to a modern art museum
and you look at this [ __ ] you're like
yeah i get it that's what i found that's
what i mean
that's what i felt like watching you
saying that you watched ergo epoxy
is like the same amount of like what the
[ __ ] i would get if you came up to me
tomorrow and said so i watched uh serial
experiments lane
yeah honestly i've been wanting to watch
that for a while i just i just haven't
had the
the opportunity to be like yeah i want
to waste a day yeah
and not not really enjoying and have a
and i have a brain that's supporting
yeah i feel like you watch you watch
shows like that to come out with like
just your brain being like what
but like that's not fun half the time so
i don't really look i mean
it is fun depending on your mood because
i remember like i
it took me ages to watch serial
experiments lane and then i was just in
this weird mood where i'm just like
yeah i i want my mind to be [ __ ] up
that that sounds like yeah
exactly right now yeah and then i don't
want a challenge yeah it's it's like
it's like me with you ask me like i'm
wait i'm waiting to wake up for the day
where i'm just like
yeah i want depression right now you
know why the [ __ ] did i give
uh this anime you sure yeah i've noticed
that
[ __ ] why would you i was about to say
you gave that a nine and i'm like okay
and i'm like was it the milf titties is
again that was in the same weekend that
i watched the other
show on the country with 48 hours right
right because i remember the mile mile
yusha was like studio arms and if you
didn't know if you don't know studio
arms they were like
no studio they were like famous for
being a hentai studio
like transitioned into anime well that's
probably why it connected a little bit
and um yeah i mean that was like one of
the first
shows they produced that was an anime
that was seen as just not complete trash
but i wouldn't call it a [ __ ] night i
think there's little sexual things going
on or something like that some vibes of
little
milf steps i mean i mean that was i i'd
say as an impressionable teenager i can
see why you are
connected with that on a personal level
he connected with it but yeah i think
that's pretty much everything because uh
you haven't rated a lot of these i would
bump kill the kill at one for getting me
in the hentai that's the same thing i
would
really kill the kill is what made me be
like you know what
anime girls are hot i'm like you know
what this is a hentai of this and there
was
and that's how i was like oh oh this is
good that's why you need to get into the
ginsengs man
um
eventually wait wait okay then if you
liked my email you shot did you like
long horizon
i loved like log horizon is one of my
favorite shows okay that makes sense
because it's written by the same people
i'm actually hype even though i think i
need to rewatch a little bit of log rise
in season two
yeah i remember i [ __ ] loved the
world yeah like in the locker room it
was fun
as [ __ ] is a [ __ ] amazing like i
don't know how
they like [ __ ] write stories like i'm
glad
yeah i'm also glad that the show didn't
like [ __ ] blow its load like
immediately and yeah
start telling us everything about it
like yeah i love it when the show's
teased us with the world like he's a
little crumb
yeah crumb knowledge and then they just
don't mention it for a few episodes
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah we are in a
we're in a [ __ ] video game
yeah we have enough videos because i
remember log horizon i remember
watching the first two three episodes of
it dropped it immediately
because i'm just like really what what
is this beta sword art online man
what the [ __ ] is this because like the
worst thing about
lock horizon was that one like the
animation is like
it's like this it ain't great it's like
the most typical
five out of ten animation this is just a
throwaway seasonal show
and the first three or so episodes were
like the most
generic kind of introduction you could
get to a world and it didn't start
getting interesting until they probably
started explaining
like the game mechanics and seeing
seeing the game mechanics being broken
like within this world was just so
[ __ ] interesting
yeah that whole arc where like there was
a guy who could kill in the villages
yeah yeah that was [ __ ] cool like
what really you sold me immediately was
like when they when they first
discovered
that they could make things taste good
and then they like invented the burger
yeah and i was like
yo this is really [ __ ] interesting
this this isn't even an issac
this is just like a like an entrepreneur
business [ __ ] anime this is what
that's what
you show was as well it was basically
just like a business textbook
yeah yeah how do you how the [ __ ] do you
guys remember what happens in these like
seven out of ten shows bro
the moment something isn't like
exceptional i'm like that's going into
the
locker rise is not a seven thousand it's
not a seven out of five
forget like this you would have whatever
the [ __ ] it's called that went straight
in the let's forget everything
maui male usual was cool because again
it was like again it's done by ton of
marmalade who's like somehow can like
make you learn [ __ ] while reading these
stories i don't know how he does it
i think it's like spice and wolf right
it's like spice and wolf exactly like
the reason why i love spices
because because like i actually learned
like proper like
useful business skills like wait a
minute i'm just getting horny over this
one or if this wolf wifi
but i'm like who's the marketing genius
but i'm learning things about economics
that's not la that's not legal that's
not allowed
what are you doing i can't be horny and
smart at the same time that's not how
that works
i just feel like i have like amazing
brain compression like i
my my brain zips zips like
you know how like when you compress a
file to like lower the memory it takes
up that's what i do with anime
immediately when i'm done i'm like zip
that [ __ ] up put it in storage forget
about that thing
and then when when i rewatch it it's
like unzipping the farm like oh yeah
this did happen yeah
has this man like min maxed his brain i
actually think i actually think i've
i've
you know i've sorted the storage on my
brain appropriately
you've got a sorting algorithm literally
just for anime
my [ __ ] god